fertility clinic yeah
so i went there and uh because they were
like hey let's just make sure your
swimmers are working and i go
this is i don't know a year and a half
ago you know but wait aren't you like 25
especially with that hog yeah
he can't breathe dangling can't breathe
choking out your neck i know dude i hear
my nuts in a rear naked choke
no but um they're tapping out right we
were gonna do the in vitro
because we wanted to like just have
twins because i want three and we just
want to knock it out so we're gonna do
in vitro like
well we gotta get your sperm everything
checked this is like last year
so it's a high level place where kim
kardashian had her [ __ ] uh
did the same thing with the twins so we
go there and i go to check in the
you know jack off and i go there it's
this mexican dude
and he's like oh what's up man big fan
i'm like yeah no doubt
keep him down dude dude then he starts
talking fighting as he's showing he's
like here come come with me man
and he's going he's like here's the room
that's where you can do that he's like
we got porn in there man
and i'm like where's the porn at and i'm
like but i also have my phone dude yeah
he's like yeah but look and then it's an
old school like you know the tvs uh in
the [ __ ] school hanging on like that
weird like brass
with a vcr and they have all these vcr
and dvds of just
this the old raunchy porn music and we
also got magazines i'm like again dude
magazines you get my phone i got my
[ __ ]
phone do people still do this so
whatever yeah because like
my dad would not have you that's what he
would be like let me check out
zika does anal yeah yeah yeah
do you have goo girls but uh so do
do do the deed get done you gotta put it
in the cup in the plastic
bag and then i'm like well who gets it
homeboy not just
the whole there's a whole room full not
to screw it all he's like yeah what's up
man
grabbing the thing he's like yeah good
time and like and then just start
talking about ufc i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on here that's right dude
oh i was so embarrassed when i filled
out so this dude was sitting right next
to me and he was like i'm having trouble
placing your name i'm like
you don't know me he goes no i know
you're right and so we're sitting there
and then the woman behind the counter
goes can you come up here
i gotta tell you what [ __ ] me up about
going there there were i had to fill up
paperwork there were two questions on
the paperwork
that that i had to ask for help the
first question was
how do you plan on making your deposit
today yeah it said masturbation
or other and i was like i got a question
and i said what
is other great girl you're a girl coming
in the room right and then girl
you're allowed to do that you're allowed
to do that your girl can suck you off in
the room do you know why they stopped
saying woman
and i asked like a while because guys
are sucking guys no guys we're
bringing in escorts i was about to say
can i get a fluffer
in escorts and so a wife came in to pick
up the sample
and the woman behind the counter didn't
recognize her and said i'm sorry
we can only give it to family and i have
to wait for his wife who was in with him
oh no [ __ ] him
up all right so wow the other question
that was on the thing that i didn't
i had no answer to was how much do you
plan on depositing today and i was like
[ __ ] all of it i don't know i don't
jerk off in a measuring cup of my house
you know what i mean
i don't know i'm not taking it to go bag
like whatever comes out
you can have and it's not that much no
you'd be surprised
yeah and then you gotta you can't like
jack off like three days before
it's painful that's not happening no it
was a 48 hour window where they're like
you can't the first time i went in
i had just come back from a weekend in
vegas so the guy goes and so uh listen
you can't have
uh masturbated within 48 hours and i was
like great i'll see you in two days yeah
and he was like did you jerk off this
morning i'm like yeah nobody told me i
wasn't
no you don't know just practicing you
know what i mean i want to make sure i
do well
i was like that's it huh let me ask you
do you have this honest question that
[ __ ] fires me up you got to reinforce
your bicycle seat
like aren't you like wait oh no aren't
you tiny yeah i mean like how what
does it disappear or people like is he
sitting on him
yes dude i was i'm surprised that didn't
happen
sooner but when i see big dudes on bikes
now i'm always like
this is first of all dude that is carbon
fiber
and it [ __ ] snapped in half in front
of people
it was do you know what the saddest
thing was so you see those people yeah
there's a group of like
hot girls over here and i was like x
games in the house
yeah off the bike like what's up scarf
is on oh
scarf is on my [ __ ] tucked out out
okay i'm in a tank top
like what's up girls did this juice
the [ __ ] pedal goes sikka off a rock
and you just hear something yeah
so i like i'm like wobbling i like
wobble
dude it's all the way back there and i
just went
i had to walk back pick it up i get on
my bike and like walk in it i'm like oh
my god
dude i get on i'm like one hand like
this
that is the last thing especially
as part of the thick boy club the last
thing you want to do
is snap your bicycle the last thing you
want to do is have it crumble
under your weight oh dude you know dude
it's like
it's it's on me like i shouldn't be
doing these jumps but i'm getting more
comfortable with the bike jumps how much
you weigh
probably 255 right now dude i jump and i
the bike's all carbon fiber and i got
the fox shocks on it the best shots you
can get and i i
i can feel it when i when i hit the
ground the whole bike goes
it just snaps shoot you straight into
the air snap dude have you not
seen the body types the people who ride
bicycles
i know the jumps that's where the thick
boy bike club comes from and there's a
bunch of thickies out there doing the
same
[ __ ] dude when i was and i would always
tell people this is good parenting and
i've had people argue with me
my brother right above me is a great
artist and i wanted to
do when growing up do what he did yeah
so one day he was drawn to superheroes
and i was like i'm gonna draw some too
he draw original
and my dad this is the type of dude my
dad is my brother walks in drops his
thing goes what do you think that he's
like jonathan
you have a future as an artist like this
is original the definition is amazing
how old is he he was probably at the
time
no no no no eight or nine
but good like real and it was like this
is really good and
your personality comes through the
drawings like it's really good right
so i bring something in for my dad and
my dad goes just like this he goes
yeah this isn't for you i know what he
goes no art's not for you he said you
can keep doing it but that's
it's never going to get any better than
that that's great parenting great paper
i never wasted another minute of another
day for you but the parents are like you
can do this like no no you can't
i could pick out we could go to a park
right now i could pick out
20 kids that are not going to be good
swimmers you will attend i think
because you you had kids so you know
this but it's interesting because
especially with
my background in sports like when
my son's playing soccer i can tell you
right now which kid should continue with
sports and which
it's at a very young age just like oh no
dude it's not happening there was a
chapter in my mind
you're talking four i'm like yeah i
ain't it there's a chapter in my book
called your son is not derek jeter
because i
coached i coached my son and i played
college baseball and i'm going to tell
you something the difference between me
in a pro oh you played college baseball
yeah we're at a place called trinity in
san antonio you've heard of it the
difference between me
and a and i was a decent
physician i played center and left field
the difference between me
and somebody who could play even
division one
or major league baseball is so vast
especially in baseball so i would watch
people and they would be like
hey so what do you think my son needs to
do to you know really have a chance i'm
like
chance at what did you see him he's he's
got his glove on his head
in the outfield he's chasing a butterfly
he's he's not this isn't his thing but
there was a dude here's the other thing
you should know if you're in pop
water football or i'm sorry if you're in
papua new baseball
and your son plays center field or right
field he's no good no nobody can hit it
out there
eventually i'm out there because the
ball is never going to get there
eventually liability
every i bet you every major league
baseball player
my guess started out playing shortstop
and pitcher 100 percent right we're
catchers yeah yeah they're like
somewhere in there what's also like in
pop warner you're if you're the real
athletic man you're probably playing
quarterback even though
you're not going to be tom brady you're
running back but you're the athletic kid
where they can
make sure they trust you that's the
thing is and eventually
you get dispersed around the field but
the out you put the athletes
where the athletes need to go yes and so
i would always like
there was a guy who used to come and
used to come in his you know the old pe
shorts he would show up and he would be
yelling at his kid
his kid who benny benny who
one day lay down in left field crying
because he thought
he had killed a butterfly in the
outfield yep can't have that and he was
crying hysterically
by the way let me tell you the funniest
thing his dad comes out and kneels
because he's crying certainly i come out
and his dad comes up benny get up
he's doing that [ __ ] i'm like hey man i
got it chill dude he goes benny good up
and so he comes out and he comes and he
does the coach squat like
this he's talking to his son or
something and one of the other kids goes
and i forget we'll just call mr benny i
want to give his last name mr benny
i see something sticking out of your
pants one of his nuts
are like dude i'm like listen man you're
traumatizing
sir bumblebee tuna your balls are
hanging out it's like
you're traumatizing everybody including
your kids yeah dude your son is like i
hope i was
wish i was really dead i'll never forget
it was a great great segment jim rome
uh when he used to do his terrestrial
show he had some nfl football he is
a legend he had some nfl football player
on and the guy was talking up his
eyeball and i got my gold chain and uh
and um he
and got off the with the interview and
jim took a phone call from a listener
and he's like hey i just want to call up
and let you know i'm a [ __ ]
i'm a gangbanger he's like these guys
need to learn like i will snatch you
he needs to shut his mouth i will snatch
his chain and jim interviewed the guy he
accepted going yeah and he's like i will
take that guy's escalade
i don't give a i'll take it and i was
scared i was scared his family and
believe me i mean what i say he's like
these all these nfl players all these
nba players who
like to be studio gangsters they don't
they need to learn
yeah i will i will take everything i uh
i was doing a show in
minneapolis and i remember right when i
walked out i look to my right
and it's all the entire tables hell's
angels i'm like oh okay
and so i'm like oh sons of anarchy want
to just get out you know like making fun
of them and they're having fun with it
and then i was doing the meet and greets
and i see him in the mean greeting
i'm like ah [ __ ] are they mad at my joke
or something the huge fans
and the the one guys probably six seven
definitely the main
dude you know and they're just all you
have the prospect on their back and he
has the real [ __ ]
and i'm obsessed with like all that yeah
that dark narco world and hell's angels
so i'm talking them for a while because
they're last in line and he goes yeah
man you want to hang
and i'm like yeah yeah i do
you know i'm drinking i'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah my brother's like hitting me
in my like i go yeah he goes yeah man we
own the club down the street man we on
the clock
guys i'll never for i'll never forget
this he goes we own the club down the
street man i'm like the club
he's like yeah the strippers let's go
feed the baby birds
gets my number leaves and my brother's
like we're not going there yeah and i
was getting a little drunk i'm like oh
i'm going
i didn't go your brother's more shows by
the way or wait
you i have soccer moms show up in
minivans
people on bikes hell's angels yeah yeah
it was great and i like
like that you know i'm like for whatever
reason enamored by him